welcome welcome in welcome back to
another edition of Market takes I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate that thank you so much for
being with us on Market takes listen
today we are diving into the state of
housing we're talking about the
interplay with inflation and we are
looking at the U.S housing market
through the release of today's U.S
existing home sales report Big release
because the overwhelming majority of all
homes sold our existing homes so we are
breaking that down I know if you've been
looking and reading the headlines it
seems like it's all bad news but the
real news there's some good and some bad
we're going to get into all that because
that's what we do here on Market take so
listen we're going to talk through what
today's existing home sales report
showed we're going to talk about the
overall state of housing the big picture
we're going to check in on the markets
because we're going to see what
investors are thinking about how they're
reading today's report and then we're
going to talk about the overall role of
Housing and inflation the big picture
because that's what it's all about right
it's all about what's happening with
inflation because the FED is watching
inflation and the FED is basically
what's moving everything so we're going
to talk about that of course I'm going
to tell you what to look out for next
because even though it's backward
looking data we are always looking
forward uh and that's really what we're
gonna do today here on Market take so
thanks again for being with us listen
today's report showed home sales home
sales fell to 4.4 million in March now
want to throw a chart up here on your
screen and just give you a look at the
overall trend now this goes back about a
year and as you can see starting April
2022 you're just seeing consistent
declining declining declining until
January even goes a little bit below and
then that February number boom that's a
15.4 percent increase from January to
February and then a a small decrease
from February to March now what we have
seen is there was a 2.4 decrease from
February to March and that was lower
than expectations actually expectations
were about for about 4.5 5 million homes
sold was 4.44 but and sales also
declined 22 percent from a year before
if we'd gone all the way back to that
March 2022 report you would have seen
that so you see the overall trend lower
but do not be fooled what we have seen
is consistently still high reports as
you see up there on your screen the
March reading is the highest if not for
that big jump in February this would be
the highest reading that we had seen
since October of last year and also
overall prices uh ticked up to 375 700
that was higher than February's increase
which was the first decrease that we had
seen in 131 months so this chart just
illustrating the overall trend which had
been lower and now is picking back up
and even though it decreased this month
we are still holding at those much
higher levels in terms of the number of
homes sold so the other big piece to
watch this February was a big month that
may have marked a turning point in the
housing market where people stop being
so bearish and saying you know what
buying a house isn't for me and said hey
you know what maybe it is uh you saw
that end of streak of 131 consecutive
months almost 11 straight years of
prices going up every single month year
over year that is the longest or was the
longest streak on record but now we've
seen an increase of housing prices again
suggest that that decrease we saw last
month may have been an aberration a an
unusual phenomenon in the data we are
saying prices pick back up again so you
saw that decline small but still prices
went back up and holding at higher
levels those are the big pieces that you
need to take from this report if you
were going to take away anything from
this report we're going to get a little
more down into the data a lot more down
in the data but if you walk away with
one big picture takeaway from this
report it is that that we are seeing a
small decline from February but still
holding at much higher levels than where
we had been and the trend has been
thrown off and we are no longer seeing
declining consistent declining
year-over-year month-over-month sales of
existing home sales another big Trend
that you want to watch out for want to
throw a chart up here on your screen to
just give you an idea of what we're
looking at in the markets this is the
U.S home builders index uh the Dow Jones
U.S home builder index basically this
index marks all watches all the big U.S
home builders we're talking KB home
we're talking uh what are some of the
other ones DR Horton Toll Brothers some
of those big names those are all what
makes up this index the big home
building companies uh there you were
just seeing a big huge take off an
increase in prices that's been one of
the strongest sectors over the past year
year over the past one year time frame
this index is up almost 36 percent and
today it's up over four percent four
point three percent increase today so
long term this has been a big increase
and you're seeing the stock of home
builders rise that tells you that
investors see home builders and homes
more construction more building more
sales all those things for home builders
that's a good thing if you own those
stocks it may not be such a good thing
if you're looking to buy a home so that
chart illustrating what we have seen
overall from the home Builder index and
what investors stock Pickers stock
buyers think about the U.S housing
market they think that things are about
to go up in a big way which means higher
prices likely on homes more competition
uh the one good thing you could take
about take away from that though if
you're looking at buying a home if
you're someone who's in the housing
market hoping for a decline in inflation
that also when those home builder stocks
rise that means they build more homes
which means we get more Supply one thing
that we have had is a consistently low
level of supplies and not a lot of
houses on the market for sale well if
those home builders get bullish and as
we saw last week if you watch or sorry
beginning of this week if you watch
Market takes the U.S homebuilder index
showed confidence starting to pick back
up price is starting to pick back up
could mean more Supply is coming into
the market this could be potential good
news for home buyers we saw the total
housing inventory in March 980 000 units
just a little bit under 1 million units
that's up one percent from February and
5.4 percent from a year ago uh unsold
inventory is at about a 2.6 month Pace
that is still very low historically but
that is up from two months uh inventory
that we had March 2022 so housing
housing Supply is slowly but surely
increasing uh here's the bad news though
on the other side of that you are seeing
more folks stepping in and buying that
so even as we are getting a little bit
more Supply we're seeing a lot more
demand and every time those interest
rates go down to just a little bit those
Market those mortgage rates go down just
a little bit we're going to talk about
that in a second you're seeing people
jump in and seeing a lot of folks buying
and looking to buy and and making that a
real uh a crowded Marketplace once again
so speaking of marketplaces want to
throw up one more thing here on your
screen and that is we're going to take a
look at the live markets what's
happening in markets right now so want
to just highlight a couple things here
you see overall stocks are down but you
see this difference here between what we
got on the Dow and what we've got in the
NASDAQ so when we're looking at the Dow
right the Dow Jones Industrial Average
you see it hits its low point of the day
right around 10 a.m when this existing
home sales report comes out and then you
see prices just really picking back up
you've seen a lot of some of that come
off but we didn't see that in the NASDAQ
and we didn't see it as much in the s p
now why is that well the Dow the Dow
Jones Industrial Average or the NYSE has
about 21 home building companies the Dow
has more of those home builders than the
NASDAQ NASDAQ only has nine Total Home
Building companies and a lot of them are
pretty small on it whereas the Dow has a
lot more of those home builders in it
and that's why you're seeing that
Divergence between the Dow and the
NASDAQ now when we also look out here at
bonds right let's take a look at bonds
we're seeing yields coming down we're
seeing overall that means prices are
going back up people are buying bonds
and really what that means is risk off
we are seeing a decline in Risk appetite
you see it here with crypto just
negative all in the red across the board
the more uh you get out on the risk
scale on some of these coins the more
you see that big increase in crypto
prices another thing you're going to
want to watch for is Commodities as you
look out right here on Commodities
you're seeing crude oil down across the
board we're also seeing lower prices in
Copper Dr copper as it's known since
about that 10 pm Point you're seeing a
decline that's less about this report
and more about the leading economic
indicators report that we also got at 10
A.M that showed another decline the 12th
month in a row with a negative reading
if you go back the last 15 months on
leading economic indicators only
February 2022 is more than zero folks
these are recession levels historically
if you look back and we've had a
recession we are at recession levels on
the leading economic indicators and I
think that's why you're seeing some of
this risk off and crude you're seeing it
in copper prices which is a measure of
the economy and you're seeing gold right
here pick back up as you see folks buy
gold when things are worried so that
just illustrating how investors are
seeing the data that we've gotten out on
the market so far and what we're talking
about when it comes to the Outlook going
forward in the market we can't go on
today without talking about how this
influences and impacts things for the
Federal Reserve the FED listen when we
look out at fed funds Futures basically
what investors are betting the FED will
do they are believing that the FED is
locked in for May that next month when
the FED meets and they're going to
announce it on May 3rd the investors say
the FED is locked in for a 25 basis
point increase of rates 87 percent of
investors see that as the likely outcome
but when you look out further you were
seeing expectations for more cuts a lot
of folks had bet that the Fed was going
to start cutting rates as soon as July
those expectations have been kind of
pushed back a little bit into August but
what folks are saying very clearly is
they expect the Federal Reserve to raise
rates next month and then start cutting
them back and that's having a direct
impact on housing because if the FED
Cuts rates that means mortgage rates
start to get lower investors in the
10-year treasury have already gotten out
ahead of that and started reducing and
buying more 10-year treasuries which is
bringing down the yield which raises the
prices and that's what we're seeing want
to put one more thing up here on your
screen and that is the 30-year fixed
mortgage rate as you can see that just
spiked up uh as we got through 2022 into
2023 it's kind of come down a little bit
but very clearly on your screen there
you see well above six percent still
more than double where we were in early
2021 and even at the beginning of 2022
so mortgage rates are still very high
historically we're higher than we've
been anywhere in the last 10 years as
you see there on your screen but anytime
mortgage rates come down you're seeing
buyers very very sensitive to price and
you see that little decline there at the
edge of your screen that's what's
prompting a lot of this buying and some
of this boom you're seeing in home
builder stock so that just illustrating
again how the market has responded the
overall mortgage market and how
investors have responded and that's
pushed the mortgage rate down that's
allowed some more folks to buy in but
really not a big change as you can see
in the overall environment for mortgages
for house prices but it's having that
psychological impact people see mortgage
rates go down just a little bit and they
rush out to buy and you're seeing
pickups in the overall rate of housing
purchases that could throw the FED off
of what they want to do the FED wants
people to not take out mortgages not go
out and buy homes not refinance their
house to go out and buy some more things
maybe refinish the deck maybe make some
Home Improvements they don't want you to
do that they want you to stay home say
wow these prices are too high I need to
fall back and just let things settle
down
people aren't doing that that can have
big implications on the rate of
inflation listen housing AKA shelter is
what they call in the CPI the Consumer
Price Index housing is about 30 is about
one-third of that it's exactly 32.77 uh
percent of the overall CPI metric but
about one-third of CPI and core CPI
which is what the FED looks at even more
closely uh the shelter index last month
accounted for over 60 percent of the
total increase in core CPI so we saw
even his overall CPI inflation declined
we saw that core number pickup excluding
food and energy and 60 of that more than
60 of that was due to housing so we are
seeing housing prices start to pick back
up again moving in the opposite
direction of what the FED wants that
could have implications for inflation
obviously this is people's biggest
biggest outlay the biggest thing they
spend money on each month
um that could have big implications for
the fed and for the market so that's why
you want to watch housing prices that's
why you want to watch what what's
happening here and mortgage rates and
all that good stuff another thing to
watch out for Energy prices we saw
energy down a little bit today but we're
back at that 80 level we have seen oil
prices really pick back up and rise over
the past few months that'll be something
to watch out for energy not as important
in the CPI and overall inflation but it
has a big role on Market psychology when
people see the prices of the pump at the
pump Rising they think oh man prices are
going back up my sentiment is lower I
don't want to go out and buy as much
because I'm having to spend so much here
on gas that's a very big psychological
impact and it also tells people
inflation's probably going back up I
need to ask the boss for a bigger raise
I need to look for a new job that pays
more because I can't deal with this High
inflation watch out for oil prices there
so listen the bad news this really this
report suggests that inflation could be
picking back up housing prices which are
a big piece could increase inflation and
cause the FED to have to do more to
tighten more to raise rates the good
news this could would mean the increased
bullish sentiment for home builders
could mean more building more Supply and
that could bring prices down for home
buyers and prospective homeowners listen
what to look out for next all right we
have a big report coming on the fed's
discount window borrowing later today at
4 30 we get that number that's
definitely something you're going to
want to watch out for because the FED
again while they're raising rates
they're also pumping a ton of money into
the financial system they have pumped
almost 400 or over 300 billion dollars
into the banking system that means that
it loosens Financial conditions and
makes it harder for them to affect
policy with their interest rates
loosening Financial conditions could
mean tougher Financial conditions for
small businesses for banks for consumers
even as they're making things looser for
big banks for big corporations all those
folks so you're going to want to watch
that number out today at 4 30. the fed's
balance sheet is approaching 9 trillion
dollars that would be a record high that
would be big uh you also we've got new
home sales coming on Tuesday and next
week and Manufacturing and services PMI
those purchasing managers index those
are on Friday earnings reports next week
I'm sorry this week we've got Procter
Gamble and L'Oreal coming out on Friday
that's tomorrow watch out for that next
week we get Microsoft alphabet Amazon
meta you also get Exxon and Chevron the
Big Oil Giants from the US Johnson and
Johnson Vita MasterCard many more we
will break all that down for you on
Monday here on Market takes I hope
you'll be with us and listen that's
going to do it for this Edition like I
said you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate that thanks for joining us
here on Market takes we'll see you next
time